there's like you know there's just this
little world of like hardcore griselda
fans
and i feel like you guys kind of like
put a lot of that like
some of the dumb narratives that people
create that is not non-existent kind of
to sleep on that record in terms of just
being like yo like
we're family at the end of the day if
you're doing good i'm doing like we're
happy for each other yeah and at the end
of the day that's really what it is you
know what i'm saying like
you know you know people
tend to love like i don't know
like a store like uh they love a
storyline
it's like it's the wrestling [ __ ]
yeah people want to be like yo what's
there weighing all that [ __ ] man you
feel me like we
it's just it's just crazy because all of
our lives and our careers is taking off
and just had a
a trajectory that we didn't even plan
out i don't think you know what i'm
saying like
benny on top of the [ __ ] world right
now you for me he's doing a million
things doing his own [ __ ]
west side the same way on the top of the
world doing a million [ __ ] he over here
with it i'm doing a bunch of [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying we are just
becoming
you know we're growing this is this i
mean look best case scenario this should
have been a plan the whole time right
yeah yeah yeah it's like like man this
is the best case scenario is what's
happening yeah man you know
absolutely
a hundred percent yeah but no that
record is crazy yeah that [ __ ]
tyson versus ali
i'm gonna say i'm gonna say you're ali
are we saying you're ali in this
in the tyson versus ali i guess so yeah
so you're ali
yeah
yeah
shout out
shout out to tana talk four though uh
man you guys are gonna have a crazy like
three or four weeks as a crew because
between your [ __ ] and his [ __ ]
man it's gonna take over he's gonna
start feeling like 20 20 in this
[ __ ] all over again take over
time man